Every year, hundreds of thousands of students
march across a stage in a gown and a squared
hat to receive a piece of paper that says
they’ve completed a particular phase in
their education.
This school graduation will undoubtedly be
marked by cheering, proud adults, and, particularly
in North America, the playing of the seminal
marching tune “Pomp and Circumstance March
No. 1.”
So, why is Pomp and Circumstance played at
seemingly every graduation?
We should probably kick things off by discussing
the name itself- “pomp and circumstance”
simply is a phrase for a ceremony or display
of splendor or stateliness.
It comes from the Latin “pompa,” meaning
“procession,” and “circumstantia,”
meaning “standing around.”
A procession of standing around doesn’t
make much sense until one follows the evolution
of the meaning “circumstantia.”
In the 13th century, the word was used in
reference to “a particular detail, matter
of small consequence.”
But a century later, in the 1300s, somehow
it literally reversed its meaning to be defined
as “something of great importance or accomplishment.”
Like so many other phrases, the credit for
the first to coin this one is generally given
to William Shakespeare, though in many cases
it is thought he was just using existing phrases
that we simply don’t have earlier surviving
examples of today.
Whatever the case, in Act 3, Scene 3 of his
1604 play “Othello,” the title character
notes
Farewell the neighing steed and the shrill
trump,
The spirit-stirring drum, th’ear-piercing
fife,
The royal banner, and all quality,
Pride, pomp, and circumstance of glorious
war!
From there, the phrase seemed to take on an
almost sarcastic quality, often used as a
way to make fun or point to the belief that
someone or something thinks of themselves
as overly important.
Flash forward three centuries later, in 1901,
one Edward Elgar had already made a name for
himself as one of the premier English musical
composers of his day.
Despite this, as so many musicians and artists
before him, Elgar was struggling financially,
unable to translate critically-acclaimed works
into money-making successes.
Knowing that people love a good military march,
he composed two (of what would end up being
five) marches that he called “Pomp and Circumstance,”
pulling the title from the line in Othello.
As for the most famous of these, March No.
1, legend has it that Elgar told a friend,
Dora Penny, that “I’ve got a tune that
will knock ’em – knock ’em flat! … a
tune like that comes once in a lifetime.”
Whether he actually said this or not, “Pomp
and Circumstance” March No. 1 in D was first
performed on October 19, 1901 by the Liverpool
Orchestral Society.
This debut performance was reportedly met
with a standing ovation, which was nothing
compared to when it was played three days
later in London.
After the first go-around, the ecstatic audience
would not let the rest of the concert go on
until the tune was played two more times.
(And, note, this sort of non-passive audience
used to be the norm, even during symphonies,
contrary to what generally happens at such
events today, see: Has There Ever Been an
Actual Case of Someone Being Pelted With Tomatoes
During a Performance?)
This event was, according to the London performance’s
conductor, Henry J. Wood, the first time in
that particular theater’s history that a
double encore was ever done.
In November of that year, Elgar was approached
by famed English contralto Clara Butt who
asked him to compose a finale for her performance
with a full chorus at the crowning of King
Edward VII later that summer.
Sparing himself extra work, Elgar used the
very same march he’d composed that was such
a hit.
He did add lyrics to it, thanks to poet Arthur
Christopher Benson.
Called “Land of Hope and Glory,” Benson’s
lyrics extol the virtues of the British crown
and empire.
The march, coupled with lyrics and Butt singing,
was all set to premiere on June 30th at King
Edward VII’s coronation, but the king fell
ill and the ceremony was delayed until August
9th.
In meantime, Elgar put together four more
marches and produced sellable versions of
them.
By August, he was already making good money
off this.
When it was finally played at the coronation
of the new King and Queen, Elgar was on his
way to finally making his fortune.
Thanks to the music’s prominence in the
coronation, Elgar became internationally famous.
Fairly quickly, in part because of its use
at the coronation of the King and Queen, the
march became immensely popular with American
orchestras, particularly played with great
frequency in Chicago.
Coming back around to why Pomp and Circumstance
is played during graduation ceremonies, in
1905, Elgar was invited to the United States
by a friend, Professor of Music Samuel Sanford,
to receive an honorary degree from Yale University.
Hailed as “England’s foremost musician,”
he outshone the 12 others who were also receiving
honorary degrees from the revered American
university that day.
Upon completion of the ceremony, the entire
group left the stage to the tune of “Pomp
and Circumstance March No. 1” in honor of
Elgar.
This is the first known time that the tune
was played at a school graduation.
The uplifting song was noted by other colleges
and played at graduations, including at Princeton
in 1907 and University of Chicago in 1908.
According to the Elgar Research Center, it
was the 1920s when “Pomp and Circumstance”
became the norm at college graduations across
the United States, though it’s unclear when
it shifted from being a recessional to a processional
(entering) song.
Today, the lyrical version of the march (Land
of Hope and Glory) is one of England’s most
famous songs, even considered by some to be
something of a second national anthem.
In the United States, the march – sans lyrics
– is also played thousands of times a year
while students march down the aisles in anticipation
of receiving their diplomas.